while she thinks she's a maverick he
drives into oncoming traffic
yeah she's pissing off chi and he's
trying to cop a plea
it's almost the perfect setting for a
new sitcom
[Music]
while she's out there masquerading he's
inside a trade-in
and everyone says she's so conniving
while he's drunk driving
and when there's trouble overseas from
conflicts with the taiwanese it's the
pelosi's baby
wow
you know gene's standing over there i
told gene can you make something truly
awful
and he said i'll give it a shot
and he forgot to put the uh the little
uh apostrophe and the pelosi's oh
there's no poll there's no apostrophe
and pelosi interesting it sounds like an
illness you've got pelosis
[Laughter]
anyway as you know nancy left taiwan on
wednesday after meeting with lawmakers
and offering u.s support for the island
that china claims has its own china had
threatened a forceful response if she
visited and they ramped up their live
fire drills around taiwan upon her
arrival they also threatened to shoot
wooden stakes and garlic at pelosi's
plane
but old nance waved it off and even took
a jab at china's prez
whatever china was going to do they will
do in their own good time but there are
certain insecurities on the part of the
president of china as to his own
political situation that he's rattling a
saber i don't know rattling his saber
now for most of us that's a euphemism
but being that she's 120 years old she
means it literally
bottom line nancy's sparking conflict
with china after telling everyone else
to shut up about china remember this is
the same person who said it was racist
to call kova the china virus and told
our olympians to keep quiet during the
beijing games
i would say to our athletes
you're there to compete
do not risk
incurring the anger of the chinese
government because they are ruthless i'd
call her a two-face but that was four
faces ago
so yeah
i love that huh
so her visit may do nothing more than
create more conflict with china which
means they'll just cozy up with russia
but maybe the trip will pay dividends at
least to the stocks her husband bought
meanwhile there are new details about
her husband paul's dui arrest court
documents reveal he had a drug in his
system was slurring his speech and
handed cops a california highway patrol
donor card
so it looks like he tried to weasel his
way out because he knew he'd failed the
sobriety test and really he had no
excuse to drink his wife was 3 000 miles
away
terrible
what a jerk
but what a jerk for using that privilege
card those should be reserved for
average joes and not for people in power
no uh uh uh-uh carl no more microwaving
fish at the office we've had enough
well i got news for you pal
i can do whatever i want
you microwave all the fish you want
this guy slept with nancy pelosi
[Applause]
so cat you know what gets me i was
thinking about this this morning what
pissed me off about this
pelosi going to a country to provoke an
enemy is exactly what they kept saying
trump was going to do that he was a good
he was going to provoke our enemies he's
unstable he could start world war three
and what happens we're ha we're
basically in a war with russia right now
and we're trying to spark a conflict
with china
right i agree with that because i mean
her trip
what did her going there do to make
anyone safer or to help taiwan at all if
anything it just pissed china off
and could have actually had the opposite
effect but it makes her look good and it
makes her look tough
and i think that's what all of this is
about plus you just can't you know stuff
with her husband you can't really
i don't know you can't really trust them
i mean he's the best guester in the
world in the finance world at least and
he didn't know couldn't guess you
shouldn't drive hopped up on boos and
pills
and
they're probably fighting a lot yeah
scream at each other but they decide to
stay together and raise their
investments
yeah
they're staying together
yeah they say that stay together for the
investments their venture capital needs
both parents exactly exactly you gotta
you gotta keep that beautiful mansion
clean tyrus it ain't broke yeah the only
but the thing is she never cared about
uh about being by uh i guess like being
brave against china she was telling
everybody not to be cutter some slack
man i mean it's never good to go to a
country during invasion season
innovation you know there's a whole
thing refugees on the beach and stuff
it's you know it's tough when you're
trying to get a tan listen uh i think
she went on a shopping spree
uh the spot's hot she brought a bunch of
empty suitcases and airports too and
you know got to get toys for the kid
where better to go than taiwan
everything's made there so
um
there's
a pretty good chance she was just seeing
like so what are you guys investing in
uh what oh is this a new product is this
we're gonna do
what kind of tank you're going to
hey sober up i need you to invest 20 on
this and then they're going to do this
do that
so
i'm just speculating i'm speculating and
the other side of it is if at least we
got to have one tough person in the
white house but hey kids at home if you
ever want to see what it looks like when
another country has dirt on you
watch our president respond to china
threatening the leader of our house
that's when you're in somebody's back
pocket ah interesting
jamie
do you wish you had like a little donor
card to get you out of problems oh yeah
i could really you're right this he
doesn't need this kind of help he's a
powerful guy i would love a card like
that and um i
i heard that biden did
try to call uh pelosi and tell her not
to go but by mistake he made the call on
his iron
and um
[Laughter]
how was the phone call it was hotter
than i expected um
i uh
[Laughter]
this is the first time maybe i'm
ignorant this is the first time i've
ever heard the phrase saber rattling in
my entire life really i swear to god i
always thought that was like the most
you could get away with at a strip club
without getting kicked out
that's neighbor i think that's what it
means right yes i think you're right
you're right do you kind of feel bad for
her i feel like her husband's get out of
jail free card
should be that he has to be married to
her
like i think that's enough yeah it's
like have you seen my wife i got drunk
and drove away and they'd be like oh
get on with it
[Laughter]
p.a.b i think what's most nauseating is
that
he's a rich drunk who tried to use the
privileged card on the cops and it's
like if you're you know it's kind of
tacky and gross those cards are for
everybody else not you absolutely
yeah i also love the fact that it didn't
work you know i got to give credit to
the cops you know he's like look here's
my donor card and they said oh that's
nice you're under arrest and yeah now he
wants a refund so i love that the fact
that the cops just said we're gonna do
it anyway um but i have to agree with
tyrus when it comes to why nancy pelosi
went over there
you know probably a couple of reasons
one she wanted to get away from him as
kat said in all of his issues but also
she's trying to maybe you know draw
attention away from all the problems
that we have here and she got some
bipartisan support for not caving in to
china so i think it was a win for her
but the real question is um why was
biden on the other side yeah no it's
interesting and it's weird it's like it
does sound familiar to me a country
warns us repeatedly of a red line uh and
we cross it then they violate
international law and then you got a war
i mean it sounds a little bit like
something that happened about six months
ago okay
all right up next something's gone wrong
with this beyonce song hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else